[Музика]
siempre VA – це не буя – енергія бою,
коли ви використовуєте аналітичну теорему,
подивіться на ці прекрасні картинки, про що, на
вашу думку, ми будемо говорити,
я думаю, це зрозуміло, бо,
судячи з фотографій, що  ви можете бачити
на екрані, ми розуміємо це, ми
будемо говорити про карнавали та
фестивалі Yahoo Padova Desna millones
castanos rosa mill Oprah Show Bodhi time
OVA mu production manager thanos Lavanya
є уникнутим рухом на Pro Carnevale
якщо святковий Оллі та я думаю, що можливо
багато з вас уже були у Венеції,
тому ті, хто був у Венеції,
обов'язково впізнають маски та
картинки, які на екрані, тож
це тема, яку ми сьогодні будемо
обговорювати фестивалі та карнавали О
Джош Адам перш за все II  на карнавалі
ми продовжуємо нашу тему святкування
і звичайно фестивалі та карнавали
це просто різні види свят,
тому сьогодні ми звернемо увагу на
такі святкування  на фестивалі та
карнавали, і перш ніж ми почнемо робити
щось інше, звичайно, як завжди, у вас
є кілька нових слів і деякі слова, які
ми вже вивчили більшість ісламських
чилі Павіні лави t8 m наша ось Y de
una super Alex leave take is novotná
women de  commode exotic observe
Чилі потрібна пані, нащадки, від яких він відмовився,
має бути так приблизно, тому давайте поглянемо,
давайте подивимося на список
слів, і вам давно пора відкрити
свої робочі зошити, взяти ручку чи олівець
і записати  слова так, особливо
ті слова, які ви, можливо, не знаєте,
тому перше, звичайно, фестиваль,
тому що сьогодні ми будемо говорити про
фестивалі фестиваль фестиваль,
карнавал, карнавальні урочистості
змусили Кевона розважити Розві shotty
entertainment rez Vava і розвага
також є синонімом  коала бхава маска
талісман костюм костюм одягаються, але
в серці є обитель AHA - coos - Matt
Lieberman Альбукерке фестиваль карнавал
oh boo boo do Co Co Co Ваня паради я
думаю  Ви пам'ятаєте, що за словами нашого
виступу підвищуються наші найпопулярніші сьогодні захворювання грудної клітки,
які я вперше оцінив
карнавал ой бух курка шоколад q
Ваня він теми виступу про
епоху шоу це може бути будь-яке шоу або
щось, що відображається і показується
перед  аудиторія приємна sakaba
Sahab котра вулиця ярмарок дурний
неомарксист, який ховається у космосі
фестиваль Будди Юстино постійного
фестивалю їжі в Єгипті та
збуджує надія, що живе, тому це
список на сьогодні, ми будемо використовувати ці
слова, і на даний момент  як завжди, я хотів
би, щоб ви відповідали словам та їхнім
визначенням, припустимо, що жахливий ключ
– це голос машинима avant rebus неслухняна
іронія par slava yahoo biznitch Енія, тому у
нас є карнавальні маски, де парадують
традиційні костюми та традиція, а тепер
давайте прочитаємо визначення так,
перше  одна людина інформаційних
переконань чи звичаїв від покоління
до покоління
, це цікаво, що
означає перехід  Інформаційний парадокс
у віруваннях щодо євро лози чи
звичаїв про проникнення від одного
покоління до іншого через
епоху в Едо в Сохо др.  Алісія Кіз
Реджі-кіпер Юджа почала poco
Lindo mullet, що це таке, як
ми можемо це назвати, звичайно, це традиція,
наступне – це громадське святкування,
яке включає людей, які рухаються по порядку
вулицею, що, на вашу думку, може
бути так  громадське свято, вони
розуміють, що це те, що
відбувається перед глядачами,
це національне свято, в якому беруть участь
багато людей, натовпи людей, глядачі
та учасники фестивалю або
свята або просто шорти
Колмогорова, публічне свято, яке
не є  Я повинен сказати, що гуманне громадянське
насильство Касілла і мусульманство самі по собі є в
стані фестивалю Avila Chesney dr.  Tam
cerca Vanya є luteum veliko a kill
posing - fuck it is posterior IKEA
charge negative service apple, котрий
включає людей, які рухаються, щоб
він сказав команду кліше a perver
Naru Paulo de Peru готель paranormal pay
out down a street
Ikaruga Chavo  нехай якийсь openam працює
, то
що це парад, окремий наступний
організована програма розваг чи
виставок або Hanna's oven програма
rosbach про bergna west of cabo perv
novice tava то що це може бути, якщо це
організована програма, якщо люди раніше планували
і вони все
ретельно спланували і продумавши спеціальну
програму, вони організували спеціальну
програму розваг, що це може бути
, це карнавал, карнавал, верхній дисплей.
Нема Ванесса, тут це пальник, можна використовувати
духовку програму
Mauro Wow обкладинка або часткове покриття
для  обличчя deokman це божественний motojima
motion was a creative О відбілювач, який я
не кажу маска та останній
комбінація одягу корінням
минулого кореня  Каріна лікар колонка Обама
має сказати pevnee complex Oh Yahoo yeah
kima yo Karenia vida loca mamanu LaMotta
te Keepa hold it is Manu lucha побачити
комбінацію одягу, що сягає корінням у
минуле, це традиційний костюм так,
традиційний костюм означає предмет
одягу, який раніше був  носили якийсь
час давно, так, і це стало
традиційним, тепер ми просто маємо
перевірити, що ми зробили дуже, дуже коротко
і дуже далеко, тому карнавал - це організована
програма розваг або виставкова
маска - це прикриття або часткове покриття для
фейс-парад - це громадське свято, яке
включає людей, які рухаються в порядку.
традиційний костюм - це поєднання
одягу, що сягає корінням у минуле, і традиції
- це людина, яка вірить, або
костюми від одного покоління до іншого,
і, звичайно, настав час поговорити
про головне, ймовірно,  Найважливіший і
найвідоміший карнавал у світі, що
карнавал у Венеції чи карнавали у
Венеції чи національний карнавал не є нашим не
Будда Махабхарата  a catotti a parallel
narubu заслужив Anjum pro-muslim на моєму
відео Mr.  Carnevale надає різноманітні
солодощі карнавал Vanetti the
procrastinator hip Doozer Harnett дозує
серйозно в мусульманському Disney є
ніч для обміну в Я сумую за тобою,
милий,
тому перед тим, як ми почнемо виконувати наше
завдання та читати цю статтю Stags,
ми збираємося перевірити слова  тому я
знайшов кілька слів з тих часів
у деяких словах, які можуть бути пов’язані з
темою до теми карнавалів, і я
додав для вас деякий переклад,
тому перш ніж почати читати, давайте перевіримо
словниковий запас, це допоможе вам
зрозуміти все, і вам
доведеться  читай разом зі мною і виконуй
завдання папуга здібності, які не гепард
туризм chamoy yo meter of dong на
правильній дозі rudenko colada - lavake Jasna
лінивець texty gizmo shit van de palma de
cresci резюме тиснути на твоє тіло Тимур
oj щорічно скажи, чи потрібно кожному  відомий
фестиваль бадамі – це не липкий фестиваль
національний проти ігуани, яка могла б з
Читрадурга добра тримати зонд дивна маска
маска поганий сон порцеланова шкіра
Ша  кіра пір'я спірія традиція
традиція карнавал карнавал у Венеції той самий
чоловік де венеція важливий був
дійсно суспільство така швидкість сильна
ojou-sama's Mazama bruschetta moto x pro
carnival vanetti booboo detection a
tourism sim know you but great craig
show, which OS звужує Аніту Верді до
специфічних  рукав досягти приблизно
так, бамперети стіл турецька іграшка
Чарльз калібр куля вийшов Wilbur
weenie будет почав клацнути
рукав або побачити опору втечу,
тому під час читання зверніть увагу
на слова, які можуть бути вам незнайомими,
а також ви повинні заповнити
пропуски
так, і у нас є список слів, у нас
є невелике слово Банк слів, які
потрібно заповнити в пропусках
О Джейкі печка і реверберація буддійська
порожнина шкіра шакіра я ігуменя Кіра
порцеляна порцеляна звіт Алана маски
маски карнавал наша оглядач лава
карнавал щорічний повинен кожен
Відсвяткуємо вечірку
zeppco, ми почнемо, Варус – це невелике італійське
місто, відоме на весь світ
rld banette це малайський каталізатор командна
стадія створіть відео mana waste sleep
Венеція відома не тільки тим, що це
дуже старе бюро
та унікальне, всі знають про
карнавали, які проводяться
щороку, коли я бачу на
уроці Selma повністю паровий етап спокійного яка  a
yam кожний купол empezamos neato маленький
ключ, щоб рухатися на рогі піхви Олени
зірка євнух Аллах Аллах фон Ов'єдо
пропустив для нього карнавал негайно за
умови такого оригінального, згідно з
легендою, щось у Венеції має
давню традицію та історію показувати емоції
ми повинні  Почали з того, що ми не
відкривали карнавал у Венеції, щоб зробити історію карнавал
Ванетті моя улюблена традиція авеню
для вашої історії або J що ми маємо
заповнити на карнавалі Венеції
люди почали щось робити в 1162 році,
але це стало дуже популярним і
добре  -відомий у 16-17 столітті ciao
mamma jammas cos ставлення shanem trabajo
de dooda Pacelli tserkov мистецтво це
карнавал листяні іграшки - барабанщик або
королівський король Аллах д.  idn't above us was here
pop alarm st if you doing a error
oh she not - Thomas Ignite Sir Thomas
to reach Так що має йти туди
святкувати люди почали святкувати
добре покажи мені Massimo почав
шоу Терези приятель Тім OVA завжди був
важлива річ у ворожіннях, карнавал,
люди могли носити їх під час
сезону карнавалу. Покажіть вам музику, яку ніхто не
приніс додому, два куплети, о, ні,
карнавал,
який я знаю, маска, так, так що
пекло маски завжди були важливою
річчю людей Дамаска в EDM це були,
навпаки, відьми  - жоден виробник карнавальних масок не
мав особливого становища в суспільстві
- ключові виробники масок
розкривають причину пророцтва печінки в Cibola ludia chemo, які
нагадують багато мечеті в la Carnevale,
тому виробники масок мали
особливе положення в суспільстві зі своїми
власними законами та правилами e una  блаженно
проблем Луїза кукурудзяна навіть Моллі
ті, навпаки, що ваша підмітка
позитиви на Піч-стріт вони були
важливими людьми, коли достаток
жив Китай  l залишаються венеціанські
маски можна знімати, коли це на лижах
маски в русі добре уникати юнацтва
Ліннеї чоловіка емоції чоботи доступні
в бета-програмі єхидна геометрія
Оллі шкіра та порцеляна лижі
рата порцеляна або з використанням оригінальної
техніки блиску ботокс, можливо, Вікас Тоня
Чи можете ви технічно чули
про Linnaeus Club, оригінальні маски були
досить простими за дизайном і
часто мали символічну та практичну
функцію мечеть Алі в пустелі шляхетні
камелії кольорові, навіть якщо піхву
лоскотно наповнює його Kimmy
aquannia, Raineesha Davin Zara,
кожна з яких є маскою  в персонажі дурної сучки-
практикуючої кулі телевізійник під назвою «
сучка-практик» у
хулігані подвоює його - kimchi annemiek перемикає
очі сьогодні люди з усього
світу приїжджають до Венеції, щоб взяти участь у
карнавалі Венеціанський карнавал - це
свято, яке приваблює  тисячі
людей, які готуються до цього дня заздалегідь
Одія карнавал марнославний рік впевнений кожен
nemcek Va  ню ти прийшов зараз слобо був мій
вибір повинен кожне коліно і о так
, це щорічне свято, яке
приваблює тисячі людей
це дає підхід проблема це
холодний день його шия
міс Резнік сяйво Віто люди були
красиві костюми і, звичайно, маски
вони співають танець  розмовляти їсти смачну їжу
і біг на човнах гондоли ePro до
Антигуа карнавал новачки або ні Люді
джихаду до Сахари новий костюм Роджера
Ходжсона оч маска бонус надати
уважно Дувр за умови, коли ми штовхаємо -
це не відбувається Чикаго багато немає
звичайного II піхви  Вінік Італійський ah Lord
kahikina Savard $7,00 мені ще
раз, якщо ви записували слова
або, ймовірно, якщо ви сфотографували
попередній слайд, це тільки для вас, щоб перевірити,
чи ми все зробили правильно, скажіть
, що простата Шарри була, зробіть це з
нами  у порівнянні просто Гаваї Камю
стіл, що карнавал Венеції святкують
маски максимум можна зробити зі шкіри та
порцеляни і щорічне святкування і я
маю  подруга, чиє ім'я Трейсі
монопод Роха Трейсі, вона американка, коли
американський Колорадо Боснія Італійська собака
гнітить Аллу Віталія, тому одним з її
улюблених свят, фестивалів і
карнавалів, звичайно, є Венеціанський карнавал,
навіть коли я це робив, я отримую 1 мільйон доларів
IU Lublin is shravani a  подаруй мені літній
карнавал Ванетті
О, апостол Жаклін, претензійний
шквал обіймів у горошок Іпрський
карнавал ванетті вана
Набу Соломон вільний від Регіни,
нам потрібно зламати обруч, тому давайте прочитаємо
це,
приїжджаючи на Карнавал, це італійське
слово для карнавального карнавалу у Венеції —
це фестиваль  для всіх ваших почуттів на кожному
кроці ви можете бачити людей в масках
і костюмах, лікар, це має спостерігати за цим.
значок досяжності, щоб завантажити
переважне запитання Chidori, яке я задаю
в квадраті,
це конфетті  літаєш у повітрі,
поки ти кулаком кулаками традиційну випічку
Єва Маша до Коста Ват не є
традиційним, звичайним для вчителів конфетті, яке
вони випускають із гарного вбрання Крішна, який
мене любить, люди оточують
тебе з усіх боків не якщо, а коли ти йдеш,
ти повинен  їздити наодинці розплідники в
гондолі є Крішна Будда розпусник
робити Шива свята вбивати вбити зробити відро
і священика у дверях Vinay дивіться деякі з
скажімо Чарльза Е додаткового ми поховали біля
обеліска над багатоніжкою немає кишені
RT sanam one doli topknots página
Багато ваніна коштує близько 7 доларів, а плаваючи
через розплідники і сидячи по дорозі,
ви матимете візит на все життя з
нас Будда Pro stone як чоботи neeraja
фактичний Будда te готель співчуття
Парваті, який
він повинен надати біля скрині
свідка Будди, щоб врятувати  чи вона
домінує над нерівністю, тож це було її
послання до вас, реваючий іпітон Ядавас,
якщо курс фонології, що
слідує за ним, показує фотографію,
yahushua messiah, нещасний
we wat  ched no murky ordeined by it dream
you have unparable no you label the
pictures Pete Passat I'm loon aaj ki o
Jonahs here a tree very aunty document
lipid beotted побачити
фотографію перший катається на гондолі
вздовж каналу рік на виїмці  з коліна
доза cuñado стук у двері Jackie boy
Авраам яєчник котрий Іда це один
номер два добре одягається та носить
маски perugia красуня сиділа на CD маска
проклята Abacha mo Malou стукає Nomar на
TOEIC у ручці прихований OCD фотографія
doc ми бачимо людей  ми в красивих
масках і чудових костюмах і
останній Венеція - це місто карнавалів,
красивих ядер і щасливих людей,
Ванетті, це пан.  Карнавал
прокрастинації, союзник Таші, залишив
підказку, тож, звичайно, це перше
, звідки ви можете побачити гарний канал, ви
можете побачити гарний міст, ви можете побачити
зображення міста та
щасливу людину в костюмі та
масці, тепер у мене є  маленька річ для вас
маленьке завдання ви повинні вгадати
департамент країни Прабхупада мав
скелястий ні, тому дивлячись на фотографії
Нік шоу, Папа Девід тепер Майорка,
Вьяса, зустрічайте Опра, шоу, приятель t-mobile,
як ви називаєте цю річ,
повітряну кулю  Повітряна куля poli an Akula,
тому це одна з найбільш
захоплюючих подій, тому вони не
безнадійні по всій долині. Цей фестиваль
проводиться двічі на рік, ви
ведете запис Давічі 90 цей фестиваль відбувся
вперше 20 років тому, і
щороку  стаючи все більш і більш популярними
запасні слід сказати перш за все ці
книги поради привабливі для переміщення, якщо вони
були нараховані на річні рахунки рахунки
люди Arnim якщо ви приєднаєтеся до цього фестивалю
ви можете взяти  політ на повітряній кулі
над старовинним замком, милуйся дивовижними
краєвидами та отримуй незабутні моменти
наступний ряд - це гарячі ванни там
, ох,
фестиваль Сому, ти ми поставили котів художників
у наполеоні круто він запалив
у вас круто на курсі  для Будди
tanah Sailaja але вони не піхва
зволікають
спокійний ви кожний nee-sama і, звичайно, у
вас будуть незабутні моменти це
вагіна, коли ви називаєте людину
Буддою ви завжди мріяли про це
, чи не ви
це чарівний мармур Сем дійсно
Ginetta  Тож як ви думаєте, що
країна дуже проста, я впевнений, що ви всі
знаєте відповідь, тому ви повинні голосно
сказати мені, яка країна Сідху
Джелліко, ваш друг у цьому шоу, ми
захопили 90 машин, скажи
потроху Абомасноу  valide дай свого головного
буддистського репрезенту або H dou V Festival
pro тримай це, ти плачеш,
о, приємно, camioneta,
тож якщо ви не знали про це, перш
за все, ви можете погуглити більше про це, а
коли у вас будуть шкільні канікули,
ви  Ви можете піти на цей фестиваль, і ви можете
взяти участь, і ви знаєте, що одиниці доходу
виробляють малюка, є прекрасний
старовинний замок, це справді дивовижно,
краєвиди фантастичні, і ви можете уявити,
якщо ви політете на повітряній кулі, ви
можете тільки уявити, як
все красиво  буде дивитися з цієї відстані
та висоти, так, чим більше ти, кубинец,
зараз на фестивалі про се, актуальний,
коли віра громада panniers приходять o
povo веде ні навчати інформації
ви повинні жити в кваліфікованого механіка OA
один флот будда сказав, що у нього було
літо  інший фестиваль - це китайський
новорічний фестиваль, кожен фестиваль гарненький
Мічиган наближається до часу поверхневого пристрою,
який Ко Ваня Навахо кокетливий
Каннаваро,
так що робити дзюдо, дзюдо, я означає, що це епоксидна смола
майже повинна бути фестивалем.
відзначається не тільки в Китаї
Аліса рідини була рідною катією
почомил до семітського самоїда Сема
буберела святкування триває 15
днів, якщо це qivana скажи, що мій вихованець не сказав, що
вам потрібно з повіскою така-кун
нам або робити англійську здавалося неслухняним
зазвичай люди влаштовують вечері та
збираються разом зі своїми сім'ями
шматочки, які я підходжу до дому до
розміщеного кооперативного відео через  коні
Онидзука Ваня Лудум відновив свою різноманітність
імені за умови, що цього тижня заревів досягти
серйозного чола легко дозвольте мені
дати вам ключ на здоров'я є
цікава традиція відкривати двері
та вікна, щоб старий рік пішов і
новий рік  приходьте унікальний
галстук Ішікава Тредічі, якщо їй
дуже потрібен дуже маленький магазин, ми опублікували історію, прочитану
в дописі, записаному в останній
день фестивалю, тут проходить парад для
Стенлі / дивно, що на цьому так
багато людей,
люди були в національних костюмах  а
вулиці й міста виглядають настільки яскраво, що
ідея Людовіка буде національні костюми
традиційні костюми для Жанни Марі
є приманками для мене II Mr.  піратський голос і
нах не вагіна так описано в ісламі
танець лева чи дракона - це ще одна
традиція, яка повинна принести
удачу університет Квебеку традиційні
гітари Баришнікова Каннаваро
Бхувана так, особливо також чорний Танах Гра,
куток біля лева, і вважається,
що він висушує добре  пощастить, якщо вчений
навіть вимовить це.
Діти Адачі отримають гроші в червоних конвертах в
цей день, якщо тепер додати винагороду,
яку Warnock перетворює-автомобілю зараз
, зараз ви збираєтеся подивитися
відео, я запитав свого друга вчителя
яка працює в Малайзії, щоб розповісти нам більше
про цей чудовий фестиваль та про
деякі інші фестивалі, тому вона люб'язно
погодилася записати відео спеціально для
вас рік 5 jigaboo Priscilla's reporter
hue, тому що є гарненька Малайзія, тому що
я розробляю ракету я знімаю
Atticus pro в Читрі  DCFS Diwali Oh Jo
Moody Dover Society, котра ніч є
Бахаттін Омахи до Чикаго в чотирьох
може побачити льодяник, коли ви подивитеся
на доджо vaj  на
EXO Vasa gated Roca, яка машина запитає
нас з Рітою, нам вдалося
відповісти на запитання про Aboya від Арчі Аками, Hashas,
ті, що вижила в Луїсвіллі, і якщо у вас є м
жливість просто призупинити відео та
о-справжньому, чи не варто його по
лухати  більше часу робіть це так, тому що в інший
раз, коли ви прослухаєте відео
не один, а два або три рази, ви
зрозумієте його набагато краще
харизма, тому ви повинні робити нотатки, ви
повинні бути дуже уважними та обережними
, слухаючи та насолоджуйтесь привітом усім
із сонячної Малайзії це країна, яка
розташована на південному сході Азії,
це плавильний котел різних культур,
малайські індійці та китайці живуть тут
разом, вони  має багато традицій і
свят, і я хочу розповісти вам
про деякі з фестивалів, що відбуваються в
Малайзії,
одним із перших святкувань кожного року
є Китайський Новий рік.
Це буває в січні або лютому
в цей час все червоне
і прикрашене ліхтарями, тому що червоний колір
є кольором удачі для китайської
культури. Найцікавішою частиною
китайського Нового року є красиві
танці лева і дракона під гучну
традиційну музику
[Оплески
] наступний фестиваль, про який я хотів би
вам розповісти, це перевезення, яке
відзначають індіанці, це
фестиваль весняного свята кольорів або
свято кохання. На цьому святі
люди дуже розважаються, кидаючи
один на одного різнокольоровими фарбами, які
може бути складно помити, і
останній фестиваль, про який я хотів би вам розповісти,
це фестиваль повітряних зміїв, який проходить
у дуже вітряній частині
Малайзії повітряні зміи є дуже традиційною
частиною розваг у Малайзії,
багато людей приходять, щоб запустити повітряних зміїв  тут
або просто подивитися, як це роблять інші, це
сімейний фестиваль, який безперечно варто
відвідати, щоб розважитися, тому всі святкування
та фестивалі в Малайзії роблять його дуже
цікавим  країна, яку можна відвідати, безперечно, це місце, яке
варто відвідати, тепер ви знаєте все про
ці три чудові фестивалі,
про які вам розповіла Вікторія,
а тепер ще одне завдання та інші маленькі
завдання, засновані на відео, тож у мене є свої
правдиві та хибні картки, так,
тому ми прочитаємо заяви та  ти
повинен будеш сказати мені,
хибні вони чи правдиві, і я буду допомагати тобі
я буду показувати тобі ознаки добре
Марчіта Сюзанни mo zhe insist
virginia satin for Marcia bola Oviedo
Nicaragua on Imam Magid na budem Nazca
za teach Ivana Pravda чи вона  означає,
що перші люди в Малайзії не
святкують китайський Новий рік Malloy C&S,
що хто Utica Thai skin на тиждень, і
це неправда, тому що якщо ви подивитеся
відео і ви це зробили, ви тепер знаєте, що в
Малайзії є кілька різних
традицій і культур і  у них
живуть різні люди, тому
вони святкують китайський Новий рік
наступний китайський Новий рік
святкують у березні це правда,
і це правда так  Гаразд Холі – це
фестиваль індійського походження, і
це вірно проти сказу Провіденс
Кілкі, це фестиваль йоґів Майя в
цьому ключовому кутку підтримує його закінчення,
червоний колір – це колір удачі для
китайців.
сер Правда,
це правда, тому ви могли побачити всі
ті червоні кольори, всі ті червоні китайські
ліхтарики та прикраси, які
встановлювали на вулицях, люди кидають
один в одного фарби і розважаються під час
святкування святого, це правда,
знав їх Кедах  yuge О милий я знаю
далеко борден знаю, що Ной протеом земля
ку Ваня святий і це знову правда, так
що це частина свята, коли вони
кидають фарби один на одного,
а останній літаючи повітряними зміями не є
традицією в Малайзії літати повітряним змієм  не
є традицією, коли вони чують, що команда
в павільйоні Піскотті – Нев, і
це неправда, тому що це один із
найбільших і відомих фестивалів у
Малайзії, тому це  На другому уроці
дякую тобі, Господи, за твою увагу та
наполегливу роботу, і я скоро побачимося з тобою
Doozers m dot o закінчився Xaro boat о так,
вірус тіла короткий скажи ah gotcha поширена
подвійна партія
[музика]
ти